Nicolas va été touché par la nuit
dernière mais il y a deux nuits il y a
eu un immeuble qui a une sorte de
collège et un immeuble d'appartement qui
a été touché je les ai vus ce matin une
personne a été tuée mais ça c'était
avant-hier cette nuit il y a eu des
explosions à mes collègues mais nous
pensons que ça a dû être des missiles
solaires qui ont réussi à abattre les
missiles comme c'est toujours le cas en
réalité les systèmes de défense ont
aériennes ont réussi à battre la grande
majorité des missiles qui ont été tués
sur tuer excusez-moi tirer sur l'Ukraine
cette nuit plus d'une vingtaine mais il
y a eu à quelques endroits des missiles
qui ont atteint leur cible et c'est
human qu'il y a le plus grand nombre de
morts quatre personnes sont décédées
selon les autorités locales ça c'est le
décompte qui est encore en cours il y a
un immeuble résidentiel qui a été frappé
une tâche d'escalier a été détruit il
est possible que
on trouve plus de mort encore sous les
décombres les travaux continuent pour
essayer de trouver les gens qui sont
peut-être restés coincés là puis admis
pro il y a aussi eu un bâtiment
résidentiel qui a été frappé il y a je
pense deux morts à ni pro et encore la
ville de oukrainka qui est dans la
région de Kev juste au sud-est de Kiev
là pour le moment je n'ai pas
information
si il y a des blessés ou des morts mais
trois villes ont été frappées et puis
d'autres endroits ont été ciblées aussi
mais là les missiles ont été abattus par
les systèmes de défense intégrée